meine damen und herren
dieser 24 februar ist ein furchtbarer
tag für die ukraine und ein düsterer tag
für europa
mit seinem angriff auf die ukraine
bricht der russische präsident putin
abermals eklatant das völkerrecht
putin bringt damit leid und zerstörung
über seine direkten nachbarn
er verletzt die souveränität und die
grenzen der ukraine
er gefährdet das leben von unzähligen
unschuldigen in der ukraine dem bruder
volkstanz
plötzlich stellt er damit auch die
friedensordnung unseres kontinents in
fragen für all das gibt es keine
rechtfertigung das ist putins krieg
ich habe dem ukrainischen präsidenten
selensky heute früh in einem telefonat
gesagt in diesen schweren stunden gilt
die ukraine
und gilt ihr und ihren bürgern und
bürgern unsere volle solidarität
angesichts der aktuellen entwicklung
habe ich heute vormittag das
sicherheitskabinett einberufen damit die
regierung über die lage beraten und über
das weitere vorgehen gemeinsam
entscheidet
alle bundesbürger die noch im land sind
bitte ich abermals sehr dringt die
ukraine zu verlassen zu ihrem eigenen
schutz
die präsidentin des deutschen
bundestages habe ich gebeten für sonntag
eine sondersitzung des bundestages
einzuberufen dort werde ich eine
regierungserklärung abgeben
als vorsitzender der g7 werde ich mich
heute nachmittag in einer
video-konferenz der g7 staats und
regierungschefs für eine einheitliche
und klare reaktion der wirtschaftlich
stärksten demokratien der welt einsetzen
als nächsten schritt werden wir in enger
absprache mit unseren internationalen
partnern in der nato und in der
europäischen union noch heute weitere
harte sanktionen gegen russland
beschließen es ist gut
dass wir das sorgfältig vorbereitet
haben
ziel der sanktionen ist es der
russischen führung klar zu machen für
diese aggression zahlt sie einen
bitteren preis
es wird sich zeigen
putin hat mit seinem krieg einen
schweren fehler begangen
lasse mir noch ein wort an unseren
nato-verbündeten in osteuropa in polen
in rumänien im baltikum richten ich
möchte ihnen ausdrücklich versichern wir
verstehen eure sorgen im angesicht
dieser entwicklung nur zu gut wir werden
euch zur seite stehen deutschland steht
zur beistandspflicht der nato
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
präsidenten schlage ich vor dass sich
die staats und regierungschefs der nato
staaten sehr bald in präsenz treffen um
die lage zu erörtern
heute abend werde ich nach brüssel
fahren um dort im kreise der staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
das weitere vorgehen zu besprechen
die lage ist sehr ernst
russlands präsidenten putin möchte ich
dazu aufrufen den militärischen angriff
sofort zu stoppen
dem blutvergießen
einhalt zu gebieten und seine truppen
vom territorium der ukraine vollständig
zurück zu ziehen
vielen dank
der bundeskanzler olaf scholz meine
damen und herren und wir schalten jetzt
unserem korrespondenten in der
hauptstadt kehrt joachim von verlor das
ist ein wunsch dass vladimir putin diese
aggression sofort stoppen möge aber das
wird wahrscheinlich unerhört bleiben
oder
ja ich nehme an dass auch andere
staatsführer in der westlichen welt
diesen wunsch an herrn putin richten
werden aber wir haben es ja schon von
herrn seelands gehört er hat versucht
noch in der nacht den russischen
präsidenten zu erreichen der ist im
moment für solche worte sicherlich nicht
zugänglich ein düsterer tag für europa
hat der erschütterte bundeskanzler hier
gerade gesagt und wir haben ja seinen
terminkalender gehört also es gilt jetzt
in der westlichen gemeinschaft die gegen
züge zu koordinieren er hat das ja auch
angekündigt dass das heute noch
passieren soll und viel mehr kann man
nicht machen denn eins ist allen
beteiligten klar auch wenn der
bundeskanzler noch einmal betont hat
dass man natürlich als nato-partner die
nato partner schützen wird gerade
estland litauen die via besondere angst
haben müssen aber die ukraine gehört
eben nicht zur nato und deswegen ist
dort ein militärisches eingreifen der
westlichen allianz nicht vorgesehen wir
bleiben nur die sanktionen die ja gut
vorbereitet sind die ja dann von
deutschland aus beschlossen und dann
abgestimmt noch mal in der eu dann in
der großen runde der eu dann in gang
gesetzt werden das andere was er
ankündigte ist die sitzung des
bundestages in einer sondersitzung am
sonntag was kann die bringen
ja ich glaube wir haben eine sehr
ungewöhnliche lage wenn man den kosovo
wegnimmt ist das hier wirklich die erste
große kriegerische auseinandersetzung
mitten in europa da ist das durchaus
gerechtfertigt dass die opposition die
übrigens schon eingebunden wurde durch
telefonate so ist das üblich die
fraktionschefs zumindest dass die
opposition eben informiert wird über die
maßnahmen die die bundesregierung auch
im internationalen rahmen treffen will
und deswegen ist der oberste souverän in
deutschland der deutsche bundestag zu
informieren ich finde dass in dieser
stelle gerechtfertigt auch wenn
sicherlich der direkte nutzen an dem tag
nur schwer zu fassen sein wird aber die
parlamentarier müssen mitgenommen werden
auch für zeiten wenn es denn noch
schlimmere entscheidungen zu treffen
gilt denn das ist auch klar die
bundeswehr ist eine parlamentsarmee und
will man sich auch absichern dass man
die zumindest das gros der deutschen
bundestagsabgeordneten
richtig informiert und hinter die eigene
position bekommt ja das war gerade ein
sehr sachlicher kanzel natürlich auch an
sehr betroffener kanzler aber der ist
nicht so weit gegangen auch natürlich
auch nicht mit seinen emotionen wie zum
beispiel die außenministerin die war
dann noch noch deutlicher oder
annalena baerbock hat ja heute morgen
sich schon mehrfach geäußert und unter
anderem auch die diplomaten
zurückgezogen und sie hat in der tat
gesagt dass putin hier den horizont
überschritten hat und dass das ein ganz
rabenschwarzer tag ist für europa und
die sicherheitsstruktur hier in europa
ich danke für den moment gerd joachim
von fallois für die informationen aus
der hauptstadt wir schauen natürlich
weiter sobald sich in berlin etwas tut
werden wir ihnen das gerne
transportieren wir wollen auch versuchen
ihnen einen überblick über die lage in
der ukraine zu präsentieren es ist
allerdings das muss man sagen heute
etwas schwierig denn uns erreichen
relativ wenig bilder und die wenigen die
es raus schaffen werden zu berichten
zusammengefasst um uns über den stand
der dinge in kenntnis zu setzen